así es el gobierno británico ha sido
contundente en su negación de retirar
esta controvertida ley del mercado
interno que es lo que ha provocado este
inicio que podría iniciar una larga
disputa legal y esto porque los europeos
consideran que gran bretaña estaría
violando el acuerdo del break si este
acuerdo que fue firmado el año pasado
entre el reino unido y la unión europea
sin embargo hoy un portavoz del gobierno
británico aseguró que van a responder a
la unión europea en su debido curso
tienen un mes para hacerlo y también el
gobierno del político conservador boris
johnson ha dicho una y otra vez que esta
ley del mercado interno es para
salvaguardar el mercado del reino unido-
sobre todo en lo que respecta a irlanda
del norte e irlanda para evitar una
frontera dura en esta región y sobre
todo para proteger el acuerdo de viernes
santo que puso fin
a varios años de conflictos en irlanda
del norte así que estamos esperando más
reacciones del gobierno británico sobre
lo que dijo hoy la unión europea